[Music]
you created a new TBS show called men at
work and this is based somewhat on your
life are you using real episodes life
yeah it is it is based on it's based on
an early breakup I had back in the day
and it stuck with me a lot and I started
writing about when it was really tragic
and kind of sad and I was like this
probably would make other people laugh
and so I wrote it down and and it does
but yeah all of its taken like in the
pilot episode the guys sitting there in
the bathtub naked while we couldn't
afford the song but in real life
everybody hurts from REM was playing and
I had a bad could change that certain
for you changing enough it's all kind of
ripped from from my from my dad's ask
you this and feel free to say no
comments but in the last episode it's
called the episode called the devil's
threesome and it's about a threesome and
I couldn't help but read in the press
you've been saying this is based on my
life is this an experience it's based on
your life the show is based on my life
conan devil's threesome is where it's
described as where the DS outnumber the
V's
[Applause]
first of all you can't bless about
[Applause]
[Music]
naturally infomercial for the vagina
vagazzler but can't even dare you blood
how dare you so wait a minute so it
wasn't good you had the experience where
it's you and another guy in a woman now
again saying I gave up on this episode
of this show a long time ago so let's
get talking it's really another dudes
who guys talking about you guys you guys
talking no chicks around so it was you
two and of course a lady
um yeah help me out with that when when
you're the guy in that situation again I
have not experienced these things to
guys where do you worry in that
situation where are you looking like hi
hypothetically hypothetically you're
looking in the heart of the darkness you
know you're just here you're trying
[Music]
Rudolph sparkles in here
[Applause]
you know you're trying to go to your
happy place try to find your happy funny
show will never air
the friendship has nowhere to go from
there you mean with the end with the guy
yeah let's be incredibly awkward oh
you're just kind of like we're yeah
we're now on the street you just fight
across the street yeah yeah you just
it's a viewer you've been marked by the
peace to be watching today no your daddy
I'm watching
but as leek I was watching her here on
the Saved by the Bell son
the real kid the tall